Susanna and Margaret were close. It was a real friendship and a work friendship. They talked four or five times a week, every week for the last 18 years.
苏珊娜和玛格丽特关系密切。她们不仅是真正的朋友，也是工作上的伙伴。在过去18年里，她们每周都会通话四五次。
We would start talking about some work piece of business. And then we would digress into a combination of motherly advice from her and gossiping, which would last for 30 to 45 more minutes. She had a lot of advice, and she didn't mince her words about what I was doing wrong. She also was very loving and there for me.
我们通常会先谈论一些工作业务，然后就会岔开话题，聊些她给我的母亲般的建议，再聊些八卦，这通常会再持续30到45分钟。她给了我很多建议，而且对于我做错的事情，她向来直言不讳。但她也十分关爱我，总是在我需要的时候支持我。
Margaret died on Tuesday. Margaret Riley is her name. She was somebody who managed screenwriters and directors and actors, too. She was 58. Susanna is Susanna Fogel, one of her clients. And she says the remarkable thing about Margaret is how up until the end, she kept hidden how sick she was. The cancer had returned. It was a secret from nearly everybody.
玛格丽特周二去世了。她叫玛格丽特·莱利。她曾是一位编剧、导演和演员的经纪人。她享年58岁。苏珊娜是苏珊娜·福格尔，也是她的客户之一。苏珊娜说，玛格丽特最了不起的地方在于，直到最后，她都隐藏着自己病情的严重程度。癌症复发了，这件事对几乎所有人都是个秘密。
Even if you pushed and asked, she would not divulge that piece of it. Like, I had texted her and said, hey, I feel like we just talk about trivial stuff. And can we talk about your health? And she said, I actually love to be distracted from talking about my health. Let's talk about you.
即使你追问，她也不会透露这方面的情况。我曾给她发短信说，嘿，我觉得我们一直在聊些琐事。我们能谈谈你的健康状况吗？她说，其实我喜欢聊些别的来转移注意力，不想谈健康。我们聊聊你吧。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
And she would do that a lot.
她经常这样做。
Margaret didn't want to get into it. She wanted to engage with people the way she always had. She liked working. She wanted to keep at it the way she was used to. And that continued literally until the day she died, Tuesday this week. Doctors had already told her that she didn't have much time. She was getting hospice care at home.
玛格丽特不想深入谈论病情。她想以一贯的方式与人相处。她热爱工作，想保持她习惯的生活节奏。这种情况一直持续到她去世那天，即本周二。医生此前已经告诉她时日无多，她当时在家接受临终关怀。
And so on Monday and Tuesday, she had a series of Zoom meetings, notes calls, calls with writers, calls with executives. And she refused to let anybody cancel them, and she refused to let people come and see her when she was booked into these professional meetings, which she attended.
因此，在周一和周二，她依然进行了一系列Zoom会议，有做笔记的通话，与编剧的通话，还有与高管的通话。她拒绝让任何人取消这些会议，也拒绝让人们在她预定的这些专业会议期间去探望她。
In fact, the day Margaret died, her mother was flying to LA to see her.
事实上，在玛格丽特去世那天，她的母亲正乘飞机去洛杉矶看她。
So there was a race for her to get from the airport in time to say goodbye. But in the meantime, that same day, Margaret was confirming and insisting that she be part of these Zooms. She didn't want to cancel any of that. So at the very end, her assistant had to lie to her and tell her that the meetings were canceled so that she wouldn't try to kick people out of her room so that she could Zoom about a project. It could have prevented her from saying goodbye to somebody that needed to see her.
所以有一场争分夺秒的赛跑，她母亲赶着从机场回来见她最后一面。但与此同时，就在那天，玛格丽特还在确认并坚持参加这些Zoom会议。她不想取消任何安排。所以在最后关头，她的助理不得不对她撒谎，说会议取消了，这样她才不会试图把人赶出房间，好去参加那个项目的视频会议。这本可能会阻碍她与需要见到她的人告别。
Susanna was in that situation because just a few days before Margaret died, somebody in Margaret's inner circle confided in her just how bad things were, which Margaret very much did not want her to know. And Susanna couldn't just rush to see her because she was at a film festival, at Sundance showing a film that she and Margaret had spent five years trying to get made. And Saturday was the premiere.
苏珊娜就处于这种情况，因为在玛格丽特去世前几天，玛格丽特圈内的一位知情者告诉她情况有多糟糕，而玛格丽特非常不想让她知道。苏珊娜无法立刻赶去见她，因为她当时正在圣丹斯电影节，展示她和玛格丽特花了五年时间才拍成的电影。周六是首映式。
And so I was engaging with Margaret throughout the weekend. Every time we texted, I wanted to stop this performance that things were fine and just tell her that I knew what was going on and tell her everything I wanted to tell her, even if it was in a text message. But I also knew that she had really wanted to engage as though things were normal. So there's a series of text messages we sent to each other where I'm kind of poking around the idea that I want her to let me know what's really going on, and she's refusing.
所以我整个周末都在和玛格丽特保持联系。每次我们发短信，我都想打破这种一切都好的假象，告诉她我知道发生了什么，并把我所有想说的话告诉她，哪怕只是通过短信。但我也知道，她确实希望表现得一切如常。所以我们之间发了一系列短信，我在试探着让她告诉我真实的情况，而她却在拒绝。
Do you have the text there?
你留着那些短信吗？
Yeah, I do.
是的，有。
Yeah, can you read them?
能读给我听听吗？
Mm-hmm. So I texted her a few hours after I got this tip from this friend of hers that she was, you know, at the end. And I said, hey, how are you feeling? She said, today's been good. How's Sundance so far? And I said, fun. I'm nervous. A couple of hours later, she texted just before my screening, good luck this afternoon. Can't wait to hear. Three exclamation points.
嗯。在她那位朋友告诉我她已经走到生命尽头后的几个小时，我给她发了短信，说，嘿，你感觉怎么样？她说，今天感觉不错。圣丹斯电影节怎么样？我说，很有趣。我很紧张。几小时后，就在我的放映开始前，她发来短信，祝你今天下午好运。迫不及待想听你分享消息。后面跟着三个感叹号。
It continues from there. Susanna sends a picture of her outfit. Margaret hearts it. Then the film screens.
随后还继续聊了一些。苏珊娜发了一张自己着装的照片，玛格丽特点了红心。然后电影开始放映。
And then she knew the running time of the film, and the second the movie was over, she texted me again. How did it go? Three question marks, three exclamation points.
她知道电影的时长，电影结束的那一刻，她又发来短信。怎么样了？三个问号，三个感叹号。
Susanna sends pictures and a review. Her last text to Margaret on Monday, 7:06 PM, is about how she's going to come over as soon as she gets back to LA to gossip and tell her all about Sundance. This was Susanna laying the groundwork to just show up at Margaret's house Tuesday, whether Margaret liked it or not, and get more real. Margaret never answered that text. And Susanna's found herself thinking a lot about what she wanted to say to her, ideally in person, or even in some last text that she could have sent last weekend when she still had the chance.
苏珊娜发去了照片和影评。她周一晚上7点06分给玛格丽特发的最后一条短信，是说她一回到洛杉矶就去看她，一起八卦，把圣丹斯的一切都告诉她。这是苏珊娜在为周二不管玛格丽特愿不愿意都要去她家做铺垫，好谈点更真实的内容。玛格丽特再也没有回复那条短信。苏珊娜发现自己一直在想，她原本想对她说的话，最好是当面说，或者是那天周末趁还有机会时发的那条最后的短信。
I think what's interesting is when I think about what I would have said in a final text message to her, I probably would have said, I don't even have words. I don't think I would have been able to compose a text message that felt like it covered the depth of my love for her. Or the words would have failed, or they wouldn't have been enough or something.
我觉得有趣的是，当我想到如果我要给她发最后一条短信会说什么时，我大概会说，我甚至不知道该用什么词汇。我觉得我无法组织出一句能涵盖我对他深沉爱意的短信。或者语言会苍白无力，或者它们还不够等等。
I would have talked about how words were inadequate, which she would have been very disappointed in because I'm a writer, and you know, she was representing me. But you know.
我会谈到言语是多么不充分，这会让她很失望，因为我是个作家，你知道，她是我的经纪人。但你知道的。
[LAUGHS] Right. That's your job.
[笑] 没错。那是你的工作。
Yeah. She would have said, come on, you can do it. Don't be a quitter.
是啊。她肯定会说，拜托，你行的。别当逃兵。
Words can be so puny sometimes in the face of feelings.
面对情感时，言语有时是如此微弱。
Yeah. If I was in person, I probably would have just ended up holding her hand.
是啊。如果当时我在场，我可能最终只会握住她的手。
I have to say, I have a lot of sympathy for her friend Margaret's position on all this. I totally understand that feeling of, what good is talking about this going to do. What can words possibly do here against the enormity of this awfulness? Or on the flip side, how can words possibly capture all I feel for you?
我必须说，我对玛格丽特朋友在这一切中的立场深表同情。我完全理解那种感觉，谈论这些有什么用呢？在如此巨大的糟糕现实面前，言语又能起到什么作用？或者反过来说，言语又怎么能承载我对你所有的感受？
Today on our program, people who find themselves in situations where the words really do not seem to capture what's happening. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述那些发现自己处于语言似乎无法捕捉正在发生的事情的处境中的人们。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, The Speaking Part.
第一幕，发言部分。
So this is a story of a woman who ran out of words, just stopped talking or close to it. It took 72 days, exactly 72 days. Chana Joffe-Walt tells what happened.
这是一个关于一个失去了言语、停止说话或几乎停止说话的女人的故事。这花了72天，整整72天。查娜·乔菲-沃尔特讲述了发生的事情。
The first time I talked to Youmna, it was a couple of months ago. And we mostly talked about her four kids, the questions they were asking her, and how she was answering those questions. There was her youngest, Joury, Juju, who had become obsessed with talking about her cat. The family left the cat when they fled their home in Gaza City on October 13, six days after Hamas attacked Israel.
我第一次和尤姆娜交谈是在几个月前。我们主要谈论了她的四个孩子，他们问她的问题，以及她如何回答这些问题。她最小的孩子朱莉（昵称朱朱）变得沉迷于谈论她的猫。10月13日，也就是哈马斯袭击以色列六天后，全家从加沙城的家中逃离时，留下了这只猫。
Juju wanted to know, was the cat getting food? Yes, Youmna said. The neighbors were feeding her. There was Mohammed, 11 years old, who, two weeks into the war, had begun pulling at his lips and biting into them until the skin tore. Mohammed wanted to know if his school was still there. Yes, Youmna said. Cerine, 8 years old. Every time the family fled, she always wanted to know where they would sleep, and would they be able to sleep together? Yes, Youmna would reassure her. We will all sleep right next to each other.
朱朱想知道，猫有东西吃吗？尤姆娜回答说，有，邻居们在喂它。11岁的穆罕默德在战争开始两周后，开始拉扯自己的嘴唇并咬破皮肤。穆罕默德想知道他的学校还在不在。尤姆娜说，在的。8岁的塞琳每次家人逃亡时，总是想知道他们会在哪里睡觉，他们能睡在一起吗？尤姆娜会安慰她，是的，我们会睡在一起。
The trickiest was Aline, Youmna's oldest, her 12-year-old.
最棘手的是艾琳，尤姆娜最大的孩子，她12岁。
Aline is always worried about her friends, especially that she can't reach them. She tells me sometimes, I don't want to call them because when they don't answer, it means that maybe they're not OK. Maybe something bad has happened to them. And I think that this is the most idea that scares her. And that's why she doesn't even try to most of the time.
艾琳总是担心她的朋友，尤其是她无法联系到他们。她有时告诉我，我不想给他们打电话，因为当他们不接听时，意味着他们可能没事。也许发生了什么坏事。我认为这是最让她害怕的想法。这就是为什么大多数时候她甚至不去尝试。
I talked to Aline a little bit about this, too.
我也和艾琳谈过这件事。
Here, let me give you Aline.
来，我让艾琳跟你说。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Say hello.
打个招呼吧。
Hello.
你好。
Aline told me she has five close friends. They're a crew.
艾琳告诉我她有五个好朋友。她们是一个小团体。
I called them, but they don't have signals.
我给她们打了电话，但没有信号。
So you can't keep in touch.
所以你无法保持联系。
So I don't know anything about them. So I have a friend. She has a little brother. He's two month, years-- he's two months just. So he's so baby. They are now staying in a car, in their car. I told her, so you don't have any cousins? You don't have any aunts in Rafah? You should go to them.
所以我对她们一无所知。我有个朋友，她有个弟弟，才两个月大，还是个婴儿。她们现在住在车里，待在车里。我告诉她，那你没有表亲吗？你在拉法没有阿姨吗？你应该去投奔她们。
So she told me, yes, I have, but the car does not have fuel, so I can't go. But after that, she didn't call me or send me any messages or answer me to my messages. So I can't do anything now.
她告诉我，有的，但车里没油了，所以我去不了。但那之后，她没再给我打电话，也没发任何信息，也没回复我的消息。所以我现在什么也做不了。
So she told me, maybe something bad has happened to her. What if something bad has happened to her? I told her we would have heard. If something bad has happened to her, we would have heard. I would have known.
她告诉我，也许她发生了什么坏事。如果她发生了什么坏事怎么办？我告诉她我们会听到的。如果她发生了什么坏事，我们肯定会知道的。我肯定会知道的。
They seemed like the right words to say, even if Youmna had no idea if they were true. With Aline, with all her kids, Youmna's strategy was to sell them on her own certainty, even if there was no reliable information on who was dead or who was alive. She wanted them to believe there was, and she had it. Youmna would summon all the authority she had as a mom who knows things.
这些听起来似乎是正确的安慰之词，即使尤姆娜根本不知道它们是否属实。对于艾琳和所有孩子，尤姆娜的策略是向他们兜售自己的确定性，即使关于谁死谁活没有任何可靠信息。她希望他们相信有消息，而且她掌握着消息。尤姆娜会发挥她作为母亲所拥有的所有权威。
And Youmna is a journalist. She reports for Al Jazeera English in Gaza. So she hoped Aline would look at her, someone who has spent almost a decade tracking down records and information, and believe that of course Youmna would know if her best friend was dead.
尤姆娜本身是一名记者。她为半岛电视台英语频道在加沙报道。所以她希望艾琳能看着她，看着这个花了近十年时间追踪记录和信息的人，相信尤姆娜当然会知道她最好的朋友是否已经去世。
I tell her, like we know by the families. When family is killed at bombardment, the names of those people killed are all out in a report. And I would have seen the names. I would have told you about it.
我告诉她，我们可以通过家庭知道。当家人在轰炸中丧生，遇难者的名字都会发布在报告中。我会看到这些名字的。我会告诉你的。
Would you have told her?
你会告诉她吗？
No.
不。
Yeah.
是啊。
No, I wouldn't. Definitely not. I mean, considering the problem is that the area that Dima, her best friend, was in, that's Hamad City. There were so many casualties, so many people killed there, so many people injured. And honestly, I don't know what else to tell her. I don't want her-- I don't want her to have that thought. Aline breaks down a lot. She's the eldest, and she understands more.
不，我不会。绝对不会。考虑到问题在于迪玛（她最好的朋友）所在的区域，那是哈马德市。那里有太多伤亡，太多人丧生，太多人受伤。老实说，我不知道还能告诉她什么。我不希望她有那种想法。艾琳经常崩溃。她是最大的孩子，她懂的更多。
But even the younger kids were understanding more than Youmna wanted them to as the war went on. They were starting to worry about everything that was happening in the parts of their world they could no longer see. What was still standing, their school, their cat, their friends. And Youmna just kept trying to convince them, it's all still there.
但随着战争的持续，甚至连年幼的孩子也比尤姆娜希望的懂得更多。他们开始担心他们视线之外的那个世界里正在发生的一切。什么还屹立不倒，他们的学校，他们的猫，他们的朋友。而尤姆娜只是不断试图说服他们，一切都还在。
I don't think they really believed me, because sometimes they tell me, how would you know? And Mohammed had a friend from a Saa family, and so he heard that the Saa family was killed in one of the airstrikes. And he came and he asked me, do you think that Yamin was killed too with his family, or did he survive? And I said, it's probably not Yamin's family. It's probably another family with the same name. He's probably somewhere safe. You don't have to worry about it.
我觉得他们并不真正相信我，因为有时他们会问我，你是怎么知道的？穆罕默德有个来自萨阿家庭的朋友，所以他听说萨阿一家在空袭中丧生了。他跑来问我，你觉得亚明和他家人也遇难了吗，还是幸存了？我说，那大概不是亚明的家。可能只是另一个同名家庭。他可能在某个安全的地方。你不用担心。
So I try to, but-- and then he just stopped asking. He doesn't ask me about anything anymore. And neither does Aline.
所以我尽量这样做，但随后他就停止询问了。他再也不问我任何事了。艾琳也不问了。
Oh, wow.
噢，天哪。
I think they just-- it's either they're not convinced by the answers, or they just feel that they don't want to know.
我想他们只是——要么是不相信这些回答，要么是觉得他们根本不想知道。
The kids' fear of what might happen to people they couldn't see began to turn toward the family and apply to Youmna and her husband too. When Youmna went out reporting, her kids begged her to stay home, and not just home, but in the same room right next to them. They wanted all six family members together. They didn't want to let anyone out of sight.
孩子们对那些他们看不见的人可能发生什么的恐惧，开始转向他们的家人，并应用到尤姆娜和她丈夫身上。当尤姆娜出去报道时，孩子们恳求她留在家里，不仅是待在家里，还要待在他们身边同一房间里。他们希望所有六个家庭成员在一起。他们不想让任何人离开视线。
Youmna told me they'd repeatedly ask a question I'd heard other parents from Gaza talk about too. Her kids would ask her, if we die, will we die together? At first, a week, 10 days into the war, Youmna would wave them off. You're not going to die. Then after a month passed, her answer changed to, you're always safe if you're in mommy's arms. Until finally, after more than 50 days of war, Youmna landed on this answer, yes, we will all six die together.
尤姆娜告诉我，他们会反复问一个我从加沙其他父母口中听到过的问题。她的孩子们会问她，如果我们死了，我们会死在一起吗？起初，在战争开始一周、十天后，尤姆娜会敷衍他们。你们不会死的。一个月过去后，她的回答变成了，只要待在妈妈怀里，你们永远是安全的。直到最后，在经历50多天战争后，尤姆娜给出了这个答案，是的，我们六个人会死在一起。
As soon as she said it, she could see her kids were relieved. It was the one thing she could say that she could tell was actually comforting to them. That's where things were for Youmna and her family. 61 days into the war, they'd relocated five times. The kids were asking harder questions, except some questions which they'd stopped asking altogether. Words were more and more difficult, but not yet impossible.
她一说完，就能看到孩子们如释重负。这是她能说出的唯一能让他们感到慰藉的话。这就是尤姆娜一家当时的情况。战争持续了61天，他们已经搬了五次家。孩子们在问更难回答的问题，除了某些他们彻底停止询问的问题。言语变得越来越困难，但还没有到完全不可能的地步。
Then there was a shift. Youmna and her husband got word that she had permission to leave Gaza with the kids, but not with her husband. Youmna's parents and siblings are in Egypt. She has Egyptian citizenship. The kids do too, but her husband does not, even though they've been married 15 years. Immediately when they got this news, Youmna's husband, Selah, started lobbying her.
然后发生了转折。尤姆娜和丈夫得到消息，她获准带着孩子离开加沙，但丈夫不行。尤姆娜的父母和兄弟姐妹在埃及。她有埃及公民身份。孩子们也有，但她丈夫没有，尽管他们结婚已经15年了。一得到这个消息，尤姆娜的丈夫塞拉就开始游说她。
He was telling me, you might have to take the kids out to safety. You have to take them. This is the fifth time that we have evacuated. He told me, just take the kids and leave.
他告诉我，你可能得带孩子们去安全的地方。你必须带他们走。这是我们第五次撤离了。他告诉我，带上孩子离开吧。
Youmna told him no. She couldn't bear it. No, he said. You have to go. You have to take the kids out. It was late. They thought they were talking quietly, but Aline, their 12-year-old, was always listening.
尤姆娜拒绝了。她无法忍受。不，他说。你必须走。你必须把孩子带出去。时间很晚了。他们以为谈话声音很小，但他们12岁的艾琳一直在偷听。
Yes, she actually heard her dad telling me to just take the kids and to save them. And she was-- she just screamed, Dad, what are you saying? We're not going anywhere without you, and we're not going to leave you here. We're not going to leave without you. What if something happens to you? And he even told her, Aline, this is our call. We decide. We're your parents. And she was like, no, you don't get to decide this. We are not going to leave you. No one is going to leave you.
是的，她真的听到了她爸爸让我带走孩子去拯救他们。她尖叫起来，爸爸，你在说什么？我们哪儿也不去，没有你我们不会离开，我们不会留你在这里。我们不会没有你而离开。如果你发生什么事怎么办？他甚至对她说，艾琳，这是我们的决定。我们是你的父母。她就像是，不，你们无权决定这个。我们不会丢下你的。谁也不会丢下你。
They let it alone until morning. They had a week to decide. Their names would be on a list at the border for that week, and then the window would close. When I talked to Youmna, it was the middle of that week. At night, they debated, Youmna and Selah whispering after the kids went to sleep. And during the day, Youmna would quietly turn everything over in her head. Should she take the kids and leave him? Could she?
他们一直纠结到早上。他们有一周时间做决定。他们的名字在那一周里会被列在边境名单上，之后窗口就会关闭。我采访尤姆娜时，正是在那一周的中段。晚上，尤姆娜和塞拉在孩子们睡着后低声争论。白天，尤姆娜则静静地在心里翻来覆去地想。她应该带孩子离开他吗？她能做到吗？
For me and my husband, we fell in love, and we got married. It wasn't just a regular marriage or anything. We're from two different nationalities and two different worlds. And we had this really nice relationship, and we made a nice family, and we traveled here and there. And he's just-- he's a part of me. He's a part of my heart. I can't just leave him. If I would leave him, I'd be ripping a part of my heart apart.
我和我丈夫，我们坠入爱河并结婚了。那不仅仅是一场普通的婚姻。我们来自两个不同的国籍和两个不同的世界。我们有着非常好的关系，我们建立了一个美好的家庭，我们去过这里那里。他是，他是我的一个部分。他是我的心的一部分。我不能就这样离开他。如果我离开他，我就像在撕碎我心的一部分。
Even if it might save your kids' lives?
即使这能救你孩子的命？
I'm not going to lie to you and tell you, no, I didn't think like that. Of course I did.
我不打算对你撒谎说，没有，我没那样想过。我当然想过。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
I did. But I felt the guilt to even think like that because he's part of us. He's a part of me.
我想过。但我因为有这种念头而感到内疚，因为他也是我们的一部分。他是我的一个部分。
They talked about it for a week, and then their time was up. Youmna told me she had made a decision. They were staying. All six of them stick together. That was it.
他们谈论了一周，然后时间到了。尤姆娜告诉我她做出了决定。他们留下来。他们六个人在一起。就这样。
I didn't hear from Youmna for a while. There were communication blackouts in Gaza, no electricity. But I could see she was out reporting, interviewing kids in camps, who told her their stomachs ached from hunger, talking to women living in tents who are trying to manage their periods without menstrual supplies. And then on December 21, I was surprised to see a post from Youmna saying she was in Egypt.
我有一段时间没收到尤姆娜的消息。加沙有通讯中断，没有电。但我能看到她在外面报道，采访营地里的孩子，他们告诉她饥饿得胃疼，采访住在帐篷里、试图在没有卫生用品的情况下处理月经的妇女。然后在12月21日，我很惊讶地看到尤姆娜发帖说她人在埃及。
Hello.
你好。
Hi, Youmna.
嗨，尤姆娜。
Hey.
嘿。
Hi.
嗨。
I'm really sorry it took me a lot of time to answer you, but it has been really a very difficult time.
很抱歉我花了很多时间才回复你，但这段时间确实非常非常困难。
She said, in the middle of the month, her kids had started going hungry. Juju, her youngest, had stopped asking for food altogether because she knew there wasn't any. The phones were in and out. There was almost no internet. They had very little contact with the outside world. And then one night, Youmna got a call.
她说，月中开始，她的孩子开始挨饿了。她最小的孩子朱朱彻底停止要求食物，因为她知道根本没有。手机时断时续。几乎没有互联网。他们与外界几乎失去联系。然后一天晚上，尤姆娜接到一个电话。
9:00 PM. On Wednesday, 9:00 PM, my dad found a way, and he connected with me. And he told me that you are-- your names are all on a list, and you need to travel tomorrow morning. You need to leave because your names are on a list.
晚上9点。周三晚上9点，我爸爸想到了办法，他联系上了我。他告诉我说，你们的名字都在名单上了，你们明天早上需要走。你们必须离开，因为你们的名字在名单上。
Her father had gotten them back on the list of people who had permission to leave Gaza and enter Egypt. They had another short window of time to leave. But her husband, Selah, was still not on the list. Selah immediately pushed, harder than he had the last time.
她父亲帮他们重新排到了获准离开加沙进入埃及的人员名单中。他们只有很短的时间可以离开。但她丈夫塞拉仍然不在名单上。塞拉立即施压，比上次更强烈。
He said, it's a message from God that you need to leave with the kids. This is the right choice now. You need to save yourself now.
他说，这是上帝发出的信号，你必须带着孩子走。这是现在的正确选择。你必须现在拯救你自己。
The three other families Youmna and Selah were living with, they joined in too.
尤姆娜和塞拉住在一起的其他三个家庭也加入了劝说行列。
Youmna, you need to go. Just go. We're all waiting for that chance. We're waiting to be able to travel. You're not doing anything wrong. The wrong thing is that you would stay here.
尤姆娜，你必须走。走吧。我们都在等那个机会。我们都在等能去旅行的机会。你没做错任何事。错的是你们留在这里。
And her parents from Egypt.
还有她在埃及的父母。
Youmna, you need to think about the kids. My mom, she told me, the kids, they're a gift from God, and you need to protect that gift.
尤姆娜，你得为孩子着想。我妈告诉我，孩子是上帝的礼物，你必须保护这份礼物。
What actually changed things for Youmna was when her dad called back and said, take Selah with you to the border. I've spoken with them. They will let him through, even without an Egyptian passport. They've given me their word. Go. Youmna wasn't sure if there really was a promise or if everyone just wanted her to do as they said. But she started packing.
真正让尤姆娜改变主意的是她父亲再次打电话说，把塞拉带到边境。我已经和他们谈过了。他们会让他通过的，即使没有埃及护照。他们已经向我承诺了。走吧。尤姆娜不确定是否真的有承诺，或者大家只是想让她听从安排。但她开始收拾东西。
So we went to the border. The Palestinian side was telling my husband that his name is not on the list and that he can't cross with us. So I told them, we're not going to cross if you don't let him cross, and he's a father. What about these children? They need their father. I need my husband with us.
所以我们去了边境。巴勒斯坦方面告诉我的丈夫，他的名字不在名单上，不能和我们一起过境。所以我告诉他们，如果你们不让他过，我们也不过。他是一个父亲。这些孩子怎么办？他们需要父亲。我需要我丈夫和我们在一起。
They told her, you'll just get to the Egyptian side, and they'll send him back. So let them send him back, Youmna said. Don't you stop us. So the Palestinian guards let her family cross to the Egyptian side, where they sat and waited for eight hours. Her husband, Selah, sat right next to her, whispering into her ear nonstop. Youmna, are you listening to me? Youmna, you have to go without me.
他们告诉她，你们到了埃及那边，他们会把他送回来的。那就让他们送他回来吧，尤姆娜说。别阻拦我们。于是巴勒斯坦卫兵让他们一家过了埃及边境，在那里他们坐着等了八个小时。她的丈夫塞拉就坐在她旁边，不停地在她耳边低语。尤姆娜，你听到了吗？尤姆娜，你得丢下我走。
And he was literally the eight hours just telling me that I need to leave. I can't go back with him. I need to save our kids' lives. He reminded me how much we have struggled with water, how much we struggle with food. What are you going to do if we end up moving in tents? How are we going to keep them warm? How are we going to keep them safe with no toilets, with no water? He told me, I'm going to be OK. I'm one person. If I don't eat, it's OK. If I don't find enough water, it's fine. I'm an adult.
那八个小时里，他就在不断地告诉我，我必须离开。我不能和他回去。我必须挽救我们孩子的生命。他提醒我，我们为了水挣扎了多久，为了食物挣扎了多久。如果我们最终搬进帐篷，你们要怎么办？我们要怎么给他们保暖？在没有厕所、没有水的情况下，我们要怎么保障他们的安全？他告诉我，我会没事的。我是一个人。如果不吃饭，没关系。如果找不到足够的水，也很好。我是个成年人。
How were you feeling during that time, Youmna, when you--
尤姆娜，在那段时间里你感觉如何，当你——
I felt like it was really-- it was really surprising. I felt deeply in my heart that he's going to cross with us. It's going to be OK. I just told him, don't worry, don't worry. I know it's going to be OK. And he was like, OK, OK. Inshallah, it's going to be OK, but are you focusing with me?
我觉得这真的，真的令人惊讶。我在心里深处感觉到他会和我们一起过关的。没事的。我只是告诉他，别担心，别担心。我知道会没事的。他说，好的，好的。因沙安拉，会没事的，但你在专心听我说吗？
You need to go. Are you listening to what I'm saying? You need to go. He was telling me that this is the only choice that we have for us to continue saving their lives. So eight hours later, they actually just called our names and gave us our passports, all of us, with no problems at all.
你必须走。你听到我在说什么了吗？你必须走。他一直告诉我，这是我们能继续拯救他们生命的唯一选择。所以八小时后，他们真的叫了我们的名字，把护照给了我们，所有人，一点问题都没有。
They passed through, made it to Egypt, all of them.
他们通过了，成功抵达埃及，全家人。
So when we just entered my dad's home in Egypt, my husband, he got into the room, and he broke down, and he cried. And he cried so hard, like he cried his heart off.
所以当我们刚进我在埃及的父亲家，我丈夫走进房间，他崩溃了，他哭了。他哭得如此厉害，就像心碎了一样。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
And I just looked at him, and I closed the door. I just told him, you know what, I think you should cry. You need to cry.
我只是看着他，关上了门。我只是告诉他，你知道吗，我觉得你应该哭。你需要哭。
Had you seen him cry like that before?
你以前见过他那样哭吗？
Never. Never seen him cry like that. I was really hoping that I could do the same, but I just wish I could. But I just felt like I just-- I just want to be quiet.
从来没有。从来没见过他那样哭。我真的很希望我能和他一样，但我做不到。我只是觉得我只想安静待着。
When she got online, Youmna saw that Al Jazeera was reporting her cameraman, Samer Abu Daqqa, had just been killed by an Israeli drone strike. She said nothing and didn't cry. She saw messages from the families they'd been living with in Rafah. They told her, right after she left, an airstrike had landed so close to the house that all the windows shattered.
当她上网时，尤姆娜看到半岛电视台报道她的摄影师萨默尔·阿布·达卡刚刚被以色列无人机袭击炸死。她什么也没说，也没有哭。她看到了在拉法与他们住在一起的家庭发来的消息。他们告诉她，就在她离开后，一次空袭离房子非常近，窗户全震碎了。
Meanwhile, in her parents' home, all around her, everyone was busy, her kids, her husband. They were re-entering the world, reacting to everything, to the food and beds and lights.
与此同时，在她父母家中，周围每个人都很忙碌，她的孩子、丈夫。他们重新进入了这个世界，对一切做出反应，对食物、床铺和灯光。
My dad was telling me Juju, my five-year-old, Juju, come on let's take a shower. And she told him, there's no water to shower. And he was like, no, we have water here. And he told her to come look. He took her to the bathroom, and he opened the tap. And water came out, and she was very excited. She was like, oh, they have water.
我爸爸告诉朱朱，我五岁的女儿，朱朱，来，我们去洗澡吧。她告诉他，没有水洗澡。他说，不，我们这里有水。他带她去浴室，打开了水龙头。水流了出来，她非常兴奋。她说，噢，他们有水。
And he told her, we have hot water too. And she was like, Mommy, Mommy, they have water in the shower. They have water in the tap. And my dad, he like-- he cried. He hugged her, and he cried. He told her, I'm sorry. I'm so sorry that you lived all this. And every single detail went on like that. Oh, my God, you have this. Oh, my God, you have that. Oh, my God, I miss this so much. Even the simple things and food and drink and so on.
他告诉她，我们还有热水。她说，妈妈，妈妈，他们淋浴间有水。水龙头里有水。我爸爸，他就像，他哭了。他抱着她，哭了。他告诉她，对不起。很抱歉你经历了这一切。每一处细节都是这样。噢，天哪，你有这个。噢，天哪，你有那个。噢，天哪，我太想念这些了。甚至是简单的东西，食物、饮料等等。
When Juju was like, oh, my God, water, and she was excited, and your dad started crying, how did she respond to seeing her grandfather cry?
当朱朱说，噢，天哪，水，她很兴奋，而你爸爸开始哭的时候，她看到爷爷哭有什么反应？
Well, she cried too. He was hugging her, and she cried too. And then he cried so hard. I felt like it was easy for everyone to actually cry and bring out their emotions, and even the kids and everything. But I wasn't even able to bring that out.
嗯，她也哭了。他抱着她，她也哭了。然后他哭得好厉害。我觉得大家都能随心所欲地哭泣并释放情绪，甚至包括孩子，这很好。但我甚至无法释放。
Youmna's family was safe. She was safe. She was suddenly one of very few people who had experienced the war and was now about to start living on the other side of it, the after. It was 72 days into the war, and that day, Youmna stopped speaking. Aside from the bare minimum basic instructions to her kids, yes, no, Youmna stopped saying anything at all. It went on like that for a week, her first week in Egypt. When we talked, this conversation, it was two weeks after she'd arrived.
尤姆娜的一家人安全了。她安全了。她突然成为极少数经历过战争、现在准备开始生活在战争另一面即“之后”的人之一。战争已经进行了72天，那天尤姆娜停止了说话。除了给孩子最基本的指令，比如是、不，尤姆娜彻底停止说任何话。这种情况持续了一周，她来到埃及的第一周。当我们交谈时，这次谈话是在她抵达两周后。
No, I wasn't talking. Literally, I was not speaking, not even to my mom, not to my dad. I just felt like I can't just-- I can't talk. I have nothing to say.
不，我不说话。字面上说，我没有开口，甚至不对我妈、我爸说话。我只是觉得我没法……我无法开口。我没什么可说的。
Wow.
哇。
I don't know. The only thing that I felt is like I have this very strong, very big, heavy concrete sheet over my chest that's just blocking everything. It felt like I could hardly breathe.
我不知道。我唯一的感觉是，我胸口上压着一块非常坚硬、巨大、沉重的混凝土板，挡住了一切。感觉我几乎无法呼吸。
She wasn't able to sleep either or eat.
她也无法睡觉或进食。
A lot of people from my family and my work, everywhere, everyone was telling me that I need to see a therapist, that I need to start therapy. And actually, my organization was really pushing me towards it, that they even got me someone. But I literally just opened the laptop, and I slammed it back because he just kept on asking me questions, like, how do you feel, what do you want to say. I didn't have the ability to bring out words from my mouth.
我家里的很多人，还有工作伙伴，到处都有人告诉我必须看治疗师，必须开始治疗。事实上，我的组织确实在推动我，甚至给我找了一个人。但我只是打开笔记本电脑，然后重重地合上，因为他一直问我问题，比如，你感觉如何，你想说什么。我根本没有能力从嘴里说出话来。
Because words feel-- they feel wrong when you're like--
因为言语觉得……当你是这样的时候，它们觉得是错的——
Because words feel very, very simple and very light. They're not describable enough to what I feel, to the thoughts that I have in my head. There are things until now that I can't speak to anyone about. Even I don't allow myself to think of, because if I do think about them, I won't be able to be normal.
因为言语感觉非常非常简单，非常轻。它们无法充分描述我的感受，描述我脑海中的想法。有些事情直到现在我都不能和任何人谈。甚至我自己也不允许自己去想，因为如果我去想，我就无法保持正常。
I've seen kids in pieces. I've seen that. I've seen it with my own eyes. I don't want to express these things because if I do let them out, I express them. Then I start dealing with their consequences.
我见过四分五裂的孩子。我见过。我亲眼见过。我不想表达这些事情，因为如果我释放它们，我表达了它们，我就得开始面对它们的后果。
What broke the logjam for Youmna to start speaking was an invitation to lunch. A week after they'd arrived in Egypt, she and her husband visited a family of Palestinians they knew from Gaza, who are now in Egypt. They all sat, ate food, and she talked. They talked about neighborhoods, places they shared in common, people they knew, and flour, what it was like over the last many weeks to try to find flour.
打破尤姆娜沉默的是一次午餐邀请。抵达埃及一周后，她和丈夫拜访了一个从加沙认识的巴勒斯坦家庭，他们现在也在埃及。他们坐在一起，吃饭，她说话了。他们谈论邻里、共同的地方、认识的人，还有面粉，这几周试图寻找面粉是什么感觉。
They didn't talk about the most brutal or scary things they'd witnessed. They talked about the world they'd shared together in Gaza. That's what did it. And when Youmna got back to her parents' house, she kept talking. And she tried to share that world with her family, to tell them what it had been like in Gaza, what she'd seen.
他们没有谈论他们目睹的最残酷或最可怕的事情。他们谈论的是他们在加沙共同分享的世界。就是这样。当尤姆娜回到父母家时，她继续说话。她试图与家人分享那个世界，告诉他们加沙是什么样子，她看到了什么。
Once I start speaking about some details, these details, they can't stand the picture of it. They can't stand the fact that we were too thirsty, and there was no water.
一旦我开始谈论一些细节，这些细节，他们无法忍受那种画面。他们无法忍受我们极度口渴、没有水的事实。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Or we were very hungry, and there was no food. We weren't able to get food or to find food. So they would interrupt you, and they would be like, oh, my God. Oh, my God. OK, this has ended. This has gone. And then they would even-- they would even cry to that story. Right? And you just feel like you haven't even-- you haven't even said anything about all this.
或者我们非常饥饿，没有食物。我们无法获得食物或找不到食物。所以他们会打断你，他们会说，噢，天哪。噢，天哪。好了，这已经结束了。这已经过去了。然后他们甚至……他们甚至会为那个故事而哭。对吧？你只是觉得你还没……关于这一切你甚至还没开口。
Youmna was speaking, but she could never get anywhere.
尤姆娜在说话，但她怎么也无法讲下去。
I talked to Youmna one more time after this, mid-January. And she told me the day before, she had gone to therapy in person. And apparently, she talked the entire time. It was just a stream of a million thoughts and feelings in no particular order. And as she talked, she noticed there was one particular feeling she kept circling back to.
在这之后，我又和尤姆娜谈了一次，在一月中旬。她告诉我前一天，她去现场做了心理治疗。显然，她全程都在说话。那只是千万种想法和感受的奔涌，没有任何特定的顺序。随着她的交谈，她注意到有一个特定的感受她一直在反复回旋。
I told him I have a lot of rage inside. I just feel angry. Every time it rains, I'm angry. My friends are living in tents in this cold. These little kids now in tents, they're getting wet. Their tents are sinking in the mud.
我告诉他我内心有很多愤怒。我只是感到愤怒。每次下雨，我就愤怒。我的朋友们住在那里的寒冷帐篷里。这些小孩子现在在帐篷里，全身湿透。他们的帐篷在泥里下沉。
People shopping in the market in Egypt made Youmna mad, people going to work, her family.
埃及市场上购物的人让尤姆娜生气，去上班的人，她的家人。
I told my sister once, she was telling me that I-- this happened in New Year's Eve. She told me, I want to go out and celebrate New Year's Eve. You want to come with me? And I just snapped. I told her, you're going to celebrate New Year's Eve? People are being killed. How can you say that? And I got really angry.
我曾经告诉过我姐姐，这是在新年前夕发生的。她告诉我说，我想出去庆祝新年前夕。你想和我一起去吗？我当场爆发了。我告诉她，你要去庆祝新年前夕？人们正在被杀害。你怎么能说那样的话？我变得非常愤怒。
And she was like, oh, I'm joking. I'm not going anywhere. I'm joking, dear. It's OK. And I felt for a second like-- I'm not normally that fast-tempered or bad-tempered person. But I just felt like, what the hell? What are you saying? So she was like, no, I'm just joking.
她就像是，噢，我开玩笑呢。我哪儿也不去。我开玩笑呢，亲爱的。没事的。我有一瞬间觉得……我平时不是那种脾气急躁或坏脾气的人。但我只是觉得，什么鬼？你在说什么？所以她就像是，不，我只是开玩笑。
Was she joking?
她是开玩笑吗？
She wasn't joking. But the fact that I snapped about it and I felt really hurt about it made her say that she's joking, and she actually didn't go anywhere. So I don't even know if that's right or wrong. I don't know. Come on. I told her, if I was there, would you be celebrating? And that's where it ends for them. I'm back. My family's back. So for them, this has ended. The big suffering has ended.
她没开玩笑。但因为我对此爆发、感到非常受伤，让她改口说她在开玩笑，她确实哪儿也没去。所以我甚至不知道那是对是错。我不知道。拜托。我告诉她，如果我还在那里，你会庆祝吗？对他们来说，这已经结束了。我回来了。我的家人回来了。所以对他们来说，这已经结束了。巨大的痛苦已经结束了。
In some ways for you, this has ended.
在某种程度上，对你来说，这已经结束了。
This has never ended for me, not even a bit. Not even a bit. I don't feel that it has even ended a bit. I spend most of my day watching what's happening in Gaza, watching the news about Gaza, watching videos. So for me, definitely no. I'm not living like someone who's in Gaza, and I'm not living like someone who's in Egypt now.
这对我来说从未结束，一点也没有。一点也没有。我不觉得这有任何结束的迹象。我大部分时间都在看加沙正在发生什么，看关于加沙的新闻，看视频。所以对我来说，绝对没有。我活得不像个在加沙的人，也不像个现在在埃及的人。
You're like a ghost.
你就像个幽灵。
Exactly. I'm constantly thinking about what's happening there. I don't feel like going anywhere. I don't feel like interacting with anyone. I don't even feel like talking to people, and I just want to spend this time looking at what's happening in Gaza.
准确地说。我一直都在想那里发生的事情。我不想去任何地方。我不想和任何人交流。我甚至不想和人说话，我只想花时间看着加沙在发生什么。
That's where Youmna is more than 100 days into the war. When she does talk, most of the time what comes out is rage.
这就是战争开始100多天后尤姆娜的状态。当她说话时，大部分时间流露出的都是愤怒。
Chana Joffe-Walt is a producer on our show. Coming up, a mother reads her teenage daughter's diary. And the things she confronts her about, the thing that upsets, her choice of words. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特是我们节目的制片人。接下来的节目，一位母亲阅读了她十几岁女儿的日记。她与她对质的事情，让她不安的事情，她词汇的选择。一会儿回来，芝加哥公共广播公司节目继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira's Glass. Today's show, "The Words to Say It," we have stories today about situations where words fail to get at what is really happening. We have arrived at Act 2 of our show. Act 2, Toska.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《言说的词汇》，我们今天讲述关于语言无法表达真实发生情况的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，托斯卡（Toska）。
When Valerie Kipnis was growing up, there was one word that her mother just did not want to use, even if it seemed like the right word for the situation. This went on for years, and it was a real puzzle for Val. Here she is.
瓦莱丽·基普尼斯成长过程中，有一个词她母亲无论如何都不想用，即便在当时的情况下那似乎是恰当的词。这种情况持续了多年，这对瓦尔来说一直是个谜。请听她讲述。
When I was 10 years old, in the fourth grade, my guidance counselor called Mama in to see her. It was urgent, she said. I knew why she had called in Mama. It was most definitely because of my nearly failing grade on a geography quiz. I should have just told my mother.
当我10岁上四年级时，我的辅导员把妈妈叫去见她。她说很紧急。我知道她为什么要叫妈妈。那绝对是因为我的地理测验成绩差点不及格。我本该直接告诉妈妈的。
I sat outside the office, ear pressed against the splintered wood door.
我坐在办公室外面，耳朵贴在破碎的木门上。
Has anything happened in the home recently?
家里最近发生了什么事吗？
No.
没有。
Has there been any family trouble?
有什么家庭纠纷吗？
No.
没有。
Perhaps you can remember a triggering event from her past or present.
也许你能回忆起她过去或现在有什么触发事件吗？
Again, no.
还是没有。
Any familial history of mental illness?
有精神疾病的家族史吗？
Of course not.
当然没有。
Is there a history of physical abuse?
有虐待史吗？
What? No.
什么？没有。
Why the bruises then?
那为什么会有淤青？
A snort. Gymnastics. Why must you Americans always assume the worst? She does gymnastics.
一声冷哼。体操。为什么你们美国人总是把事情想得那么糟？她练体操。
Well, I apologize for asking. It's just that the state requires that I do. Still, may I suggest some sort of counseling or therapy for her? It could be helpful. It's not particularly normal for 10-year-olds to write this way. Mrs. D is concerned. I am concerned. We're all concerned. Here's a list of some good counselors in the South Brooklyn area if you decide to seek help, which we, again, recommend.
好吧，很抱歉我这么问。只是州政府规定我必须这样做。不过，我能建议她接受某种辅导或治疗吗？可能会有帮助。10岁的孩子这样写作并不太正常。D太太很担心。我也很担心。我们都很担心。如果你决定寻求帮助，这里有一份南布鲁克林地区优秀辅导员名单，我们再次建议。
Yes, OK. Thank you, Mrs. Guidance Counselor. Appreciate your time, Mrs. Counselor, Mama said in her fractured English.
好的。谢谢，辅导员太太。感谢你的时间，辅导员太太，妈妈用她破碎的英语说道。
On the walk home, Mama said nothing. She marched quickly in her burgundy crocodile print pointy-toed leather heels, clutching a paper the counselor had given her. It was not my geography quiz. It was a creative writing assignment about trees for my living environment class. The last run-on sentence was, "I am hollow and dead and alive all at the same time. How am I any different than a tree stuck in a permanent fall?"
回家路上，妈妈一言不发。她穿着酒红色鳄鱼纹尖头皮鞋快步走着，手里紧紧攥着辅导员给她的那张纸。那不是我的地理测验，而是我生活环境课关于树木的创意写作作业。最后那个长句是：“我是空洞的，既是死的又是活的。我和一棵困在永久秋天里的树有什么不同？”
As we walk through our apartment building's metal gates, Mama addressed me in Russian. Look at me, she said. Are you sad, Lera? No, I'm fine, Mama. Your stupid counselor seems to think you are depressed, she said as she opened the door to our apartment, gesturing with her fingers to make quotation signs in the air around the word "depressed."
当我们穿过公寓大楼的金属大门时，妈妈用俄语跟我说话。看着我，她说。你难过吗，莱拉？不，我很好，妈妈。你的愚蠢辅导员似乎认为你“抑郁”了，她说，开门进屋时，她用手指在空中比出引号手势。
What a stupid American word. How can a child be depressed? You have everything. You can be sad for a little, sure, but you are not depressed. Bozhe moi, these Amerikantzi are so dramatic. My mother yelled out to my father, Marik, do you think children can be depressed? In America, my father shouted from the bedroom. No, they have everything. What do they have to be depressed about? Exactly like I said, Mama responded, satisfied.
多么愚蠢的美国词。小孩子怎么可能抑郁？你什么都有。你可以难过一会儿，当然，但你没有抑郁。天哪（Bozhe moi），这些美国佬真是戏剧化。我母亲冲我父亲喊道，马里克，你觉得孩子会抑郁吗？在美国，我父亲从卧室里喊道。不，他们什么都有。他们有什么好抑郁的？正如我所说的，妈妈满足地回答道。
We arrived in the US when I was one. Immigration defined the first decade of my life. Cans of tuna for dinner, ESL classes, and small, often crowded living spaces. I didn't speak English fluently until I was eight. By the time I was in the sixth grade, I had shed my thick Russian accent and the last two letters of my first name, Valeriya. I went by Valerie now, Val for short.
我们移民到美国时我一岁。移民定义了我生命的前十年。晚餐吃金枪鱼罐头，上英语辅导课，居住在狭小拥挤的空间。直到八岁我才流利地讲英语。到六年级时，我已经甩掉了浓重的俄语口音，去掉了名字最后两个字母“iya”。现在我叫瓦莱丽，简称瓦尔。
My grandmothers deemed me an Amerikanka. That meant I took phone calls with Con Edison, instructed landlords how to fix our oftentimes broken radiators, and negotiated rates for vacation timeshares. I could be a moody child, self-serious, sometimes sad in ways that felt too big for my body. Mostly, I kept this to myself. But occasionally, my feelings would slip out, like one day when I was 15.
我的祖母认为我是个“美国女孩”（Amerikanka）。这意味着我要接联合爱迪生公司的电话，指导房东修理我们时常坏掉的暖气，协商度假分时度假的费用。我可以是个情绪化的孩子，自负，有时因为一些我觉得对我身体来说太沉重的悲伤而感到难过。大多数时候，我把这些藏在心底。但偶尔，我的感受会溜出来，比如我15岁那年的一天。
I came home from dance practice to find my diary open on the marble-topped island in our kitchen, my mother crying. Lera, come sit next to me, pozhaluysta. Throwing down my backpack, I settled myself on the stool next to her. Lera, Lerachka, why do you write this way? Scrawled in seafoam green jelly pen, my handwriting read, "There is no meaning to it all. I would end it, but that would hurt everyone around me." The words now felt foreign.
我从舞蹈练习回家，发现我的日记本开着放在厨房的大理石岛台上，母亲正在哭。莱拉，过来坐我旁边，请（pozhaluysta）。扔下背包，我在她旁边的凳子上坐下。莱拉，莱拉奇卡，你为什么写成这样？我用海沫绿色的胶水笔草草写道，我的笔迹写着：“这一切毫无意义。我想结束它，但这会伤害我周围的所有人。”这些话现在感觉很陌生。
Because it's how I feel. I write what I feel. That's the point of having a diary, Mama. It's private. Why would you look through it? Why?
因为这就是我的感受。我写下我的感受。这就是写日记的意义，妈妈。这是私人的。你为什么要翻看它？为什么？
What are these negative thoughts? Why do you have such feelings? Tell me, Lera, please. Is this coming from the TV you watch? I knew your father should not have installed that stupid cable.
这些消极想法是什么？为什么你有这种感受？告诉我，莱拉，拜托。这是电视看来的吗？我知道你父亲不该装那该死的有线电视。
From cable? Really, Mama? You think Hannah Montana is making me depressed?
从有线电视来的？真的吗，妈妈？你觉得汉娜·蒙塔娜让我抑郁了？
Again, with that word, "depressed." She let the syllables roll thick out of her mouth. You are not depressed, Lera. You simply cannot be. This feeling is momentary. You are a teenager. It is hormones. It happens to everybody. OK, you are sad. Sure. But it will be over tomorrow.
又用那个词，“抑郁”。她让音节沉重地从嘴里滚出来。你没有抑郁，莱拉。你根本不可能抑郁。这种感觉是暂时的。你是个青少年。这是荷尔蒙。每个人都会这样。好吧，你难过了。当然。但这明天就会过去。
In true teen fashion, I yelled, you don't understand. I hate you. Then ran into my room, slammed the door, buried my face in a pillow, and cried. I wished I could reveal her inadequacy as a mother, to hurt her by really ending it. But even alone in my room, I could hear her voice in the back of my mind, shaming me. We immigrate here for you, and this is what you do to us. You are not depressed. You're a selfish little girl. This was my mother's power. She could wear me down, even if she was only inside my head.
带着典型的青少年风范，我大喊，你根本不懂。我恨你。然后跑进房间，甩上门，把脸埋进枕头里哭了起来。我希望能揭露她作为母亲的无能，通过真正结束生命来伤害她。但即使独自在房间里，我也能在脑海深处听到她的声音，让我感到羞愧。我们为了你移民到这里，而你就是这样报答我们的。你没有抑郁。你是个自私的小女孩。这就是我母亲的力量。她能击垮我，即便她只是存在于我的脑海中。
And this was how it went. I could be sad, but not depressed. I could be nervous, but not anxious. I could be particular, but not obsessive. Therapy and medication were completely out of the question. But maybe she was right. My job as the immigrant daughter was to be grateful, to be content.
事情就这样继续。我可以难过，但不能抑郁。我可以紧张，但不能焦虑。我可以挑剔，但不能强迫。治疗和药物根本不在考虑范围内。但也许她是对的。作为移民女儿，我的工作是感恩、知足。
I grew up. I moved out. And then a month before I turned 25, I stopped being able to take full breaths. At first, small, enclosed spaces like elevators made me anxious. Within a few months, I'd stop taking the subway. Then obsessive thoughts kicked in. I moved apartments, and when I couldn't adjust to my new home, I began to walk the Williamsburg Bridge at night to my old place. I still had the keys.
我长大了。搬了出去。就在我25岁生日前一个月，我无法再进行深呼吸了。起初，电梯等狭小封闭的空间让我感到焦虑。几个月内，我停止乘坐地铁。然后强迫性思维开始了。我搬了公寓，当无法适应新家时，我开始在夜里走威廉斯堡大桥回到旧处。我还有钥匙。
I would sit on the floor of the vacant apartment for hours. I did this for a month before I realized that I should perhaps seek help. My therapist-- I'll call her Terry-- had pink hair and worked from an office with another therapist's name on the door. It was kind of confusing, but she was cheap. She certified that I was depressed and anxious with OCD-like tendencies, more O than C, she said.
我会在那间空公寓的地板上坐几个小时。我坚持了一个月，才意识到也许我应该寻求帮助。我的治疗师——我叫她特里——有粉色头发，在办公室工作，门上贴着另一个治疗师的名字。这有点混乱，但她收费便宜。她证明我有抑郁和焦虑，带有强迫倾向，她说这是倾向强于强迫（O-C）。
I was sort of proud, to have a word. It felt real. I decided to tell my parents that I was seeing a therapist. I told them one night in the car. I thought maybe they would be concerned or ask questions, but it was like they didn't hear me. Except I heard my mother mutter in Russian, Amerikanskaya chyzh, meaning American nonsense.
我有点骄傲，因为有了个词。这感觉很真实。我决定告诉父母我正在看治疗师。一天晚上在车里我告诉了他们。我以为他们会担心或问问题，但他们好像没听见一样。除了我听到母亲用俄语嘟囔了一句，“美国垃圾”（Amerikanskaya chyzh）。
And just like that, my mother's voice was back inside my head. Whenever Terry told me I was depressed, instead of feeling relieved or understood, I wanted to argue. I wanted to yell. Really, depressed? Good one, Terry. Maybe I'm just sad today. Can't a person be sad? Stop diagnosing me.
就这样，母亲的声音又回到了我脑子里。每当特里告诉我我抑郁时，我没感到解脱或被理解，反而想争辩。我想大喊。真的，抑郁？说得好，特里。也许我今天只是难过。一个人不能难过吗？别再给我下诊断了。
But I didn't actually yell any of this. Instead, I would nod and let her tell me about coping mechanisms, such as yoga and journaling, a healthier diet, vitamin D. Chekhov once wrote, "If many remedies are prescribed for an illness, you may be certain that the illness has no cure." And whenever Terry would prescribe self-care to deal with my never-ending sadness, I would think about my parents. I would think about toska.
但我没真喊出来。相反，我点点头，让她告诉我关于应对机制，比如瑜伽、写日记、健康的饮食、维生素D。契诃夫曾经写道：“如果为一种疾病开了许多药方，你可以确定这种病是治不好的。”每当特里为我无休止的悲伤开出“自我保健”的药方时，我就会想到我的父母。我会想到托斯卡。
OK, a word about toska. For most Russians of my parents' generation, there was no real word for depression. The word they did say was toska. After I gave up on Terry, I started googling around, hoping to understand why my mom was so uncomfortable with the word "depression." And here's what I learned.
好了，说说“托斯卡”。对于我父母那一代的大多数俄罗斯人来说，没有“抑郁”这个确切词汇。他们说的词是“托斯卡”。在我放弃特里后，我开始谷歌搜索，希望理解为什么我妈对“抑郁”这个词如此反感。这就是我学到的。
It goes back to the Soviet era. During that time, mental illness was stigmatized, seen as a problem that only afflicted capitalist societies, a problem that would disappear under Communist rule. The model Soviet citizen, a tovarish, could not be mentally ill. My father once told me there could be no depression in the world we were building because we were striving for this perfection.
这要追溯到苏联时代。那时，精神疾病被污名化，被视为只有资本主义社会才会出现的病态问题，一个在共产主义统治下会消失的问题。模范苏联公民，一个同志（tovarish），是不可能精神失常的。我父亲曾告诉我，在我们正在建设的世界里不可能有抑郁，因为我们正在追求这种完美。
They did use the word "depresiya," but it felt like a foreign import. And anyway, it was reserved for those in the highest rung of emotional distress, those who had lost a spouse in war or a child at birth, and not much else. And there was another much more menacing way Soviets talked about mental illness, and that was as a political weapon. Political and cultural dissidents were pronounced mentally ill, unsound of mind, and locked up in psychiatric hospitals.
他们确实使用“depresiya”这个词，但感觉像是外国进口的。无论如何，它只保留给处于最高情绪困境的人，比如在战争中失去配偶或生孩子时失去孩子的人，除此之外别无其他。苏联人还有另一种更具威胁性的谈论精神疾病的方式，那就是作为政治武器。政治和文化异见者会被宣布为精神失常、心智不健全，并被关进精神病院。
It was a very dark Soviet logic. You couldn't be mentally ill and be a model Soviet citizen. But at the same time, if you were not a model Soviet citizen, well, the reason for that was, you were mentally ill. And if you were just a person who wanted to see a psychiatrist, like people did in the West, well, therapy was essentially banned by Soviet authorities for three generations.
那是一种非常黑暗的苏联逻辑。你不可能既是精神失常又是模范苏联公民。但同时，如果你不是模范苏联公民，原因就是你精神失常了。而如果你只是像西方人那样想去看精神病医生，那么在苏联当局那里，治疗实际上被禁止了三代人。
Every person who received psychiatric treatment, even just a consultation, was registered by the state. After that, it could be difficult to apply for work or keep jobs. Whatever psychiatry did exist was mostly underground. Mostly things stayed this way until the 1990s, until the Soviet Union fell apart.
每一个接受精神病治疗的人，哪怕只是咨询，都会被国家登记。此后，申请工作或保住工作可能会变得困难。现有的精神病学大多是地下的。事情大多保持这种状态直到1990年代，直到苏联解体。
Now, things are different. But for people like my parents who left just a few years after that, mental illness remained taboo. They had different words to talk about these sorts of feelings, words like "toska." "Toska" is a word Russians consider to be, in its essence, Russian. It is both of them and for them. It's one of the things that defines the Russian soul, which is perhaps why it is so untranslatable.
现在，情况不同了。但对于像我父母那样在解体几年后离开的人来说，精神疾病仍然是禁忌。他们有不同的词来谈论这些感受，比如“托斯卡”。“托斯卡”是俄罗斯人认为本质上属于俄罗斯的词。它既属于他们也为了他们。它是定义俄罗斯灵魂的事物之一，这或许就是它如此难以翻译的原因。
I think Vladimir Nabokov captures toska's meaning best. "No single word in English renders all the shades of toska. At its deepest and most painful, it is a sensation of great spiritual anguish, often without any specific cause. At less morbid levels, it is a dull ache of the soul, a longing with nothing to long for, a sick pining, a vague restlessness, mental throes, yearning."
我觉得弗拉基米尔·纳博科夫最能抓住托斯卡的含义。“英语中没有一个词能表达托斯卡的所有细微差别。在它最深刻、最痛苦的时候，这是一种巨大的精神痛苦，通常没有任何具体原因。在不那么病态的层面上，它是一种灵魂的钝痛，一种没有任何期盼的渴望，一种病态的思念，一种模糊的躁动，精神的挣扎，向往。”
Toska and depression share some things in common, but they are not the same. Like, depression is the lack of desire, while toska is the desire for something unattainable. Toska is not a diagnosis. It is a collective sense of loss. It is a heavy weight. It is the darkness of long winters. "Toska" is the word my mother always used to describe her first decade in America. Bilo ochen tosklivo. It was filled with toska.
托斯卡和抑郁有一些共同点，但它们并不一样。比如，抑郁是欲望的匮乏，而托斯卡是对某种无法企及之物的渴望。托斯卡不是一种诊断。它是一种集体的失落感。它是一种沉重的负担。它是漫长冬天的黑暗。“托斯卡”是我母亲总是用来描述她在美国头十年的词。Bilo ochen tosklivo. 它是充满了托斯卡。
Mama describes her first months in New York as horrific. The story goes like this. When we arrived at JFK, she took one look around and immediately started crying. We moved into an apartment on Avenue P in Brooklyn. It felt like my soul had been ripped out of my human, my mother once told me. I stopped seeing life in color. Everything about New York seemed awful and gray.
妈妈将她在纽约的头几个月描述为可怕的。故事是这样的。当我们抵达肯尼迪机场时，她环顾四周，立即开始哭泣。我们搬进了布鲁克林P大道的一间公寓。妈妈曾经告诉我，那种感觉就像灵魂从人身上被撕扯走了。我不再看到生活中的色彩。关于纽约的一切看起来都糟糕而灰暗。
She was a 28-year-old refugee with a one-year-old. She became obsessed with the past. She forgot about the poverty that accompanied the fall of the Soviet Union, the lawlessness, the gang violence, the dead bodies she herself had walked past in the street. Mama said, I could only think of the beauty, the canals. I could only think of my mother.
她是一名28岁的难民，带着一个一岁的孩子。她变得沉迷于过去。她忘记了苏联解体带来的贫困、无法无天、帮派暴力、她自己在街上经过的死尸。妈妈说，我只能想到美，运河。我只能想到我的母亲。
She spent hours walking around South Brooklyn with me in a carriage and her Walkman on full blast, listening mostly to Alexander Rosenbaum, a Russian folk singer known for his lyrics about prison confinement, Leningrad, suffering, and tortured love. She would play her favorite song, "Naletela Grust," Sadness Has Descended Onto Me, on repeat. I imagine her cold fingers-- not yet swollen from the houses she'll clean, the toilets she will scrub-- reach for protruding plastic buttons. Pause, rewind, play.
她花了很多时间推着婴儿车里的我走在南布鲁克林，耳机里放着震耳欲聋的音乐，大多是亚历山大·罗森鲍姆的作品，一位以歌词涉及监狱囚禁、列宁格勒、苦难和痛苦爱情而闻名的俄罗斯民谣歌手。她会循环播放她最爱的歌《悲伤降临到我身上》（Naletela Grust）。我想象她冰冷的手指——还没因为洗碗、刷马桶而浮肿——伸向突出的塑料按钮。暂停，倒带，播放。
During her first year in America, my mother lived in almost total solitude. My father was in school during the day and working as a dishwasher in a Burrow Park restaurant by night. For company, she had only me, a crying baby. Mama said, I felt unnecessary in this country. I felt unnecessary to myself. I was an adult woman with an engineering degree, and here I was sitting at home all day, not knowing how to ask for directions or buy food if I was starving. I felt like I might as well just roll over and die. She'd say, Tosklivo bilo mne. Toska had come over me.
在美国的第一年，我母亲几乎完全处于孤独中。我父亲白天上学，晚上在伯勒公园的一家餐馆洗碗。陪伴她的只有我，一个哭闹的婴儿。妈妈说，在这个国家我感到多余。我觉得自己对自己来说也是多余的。我是一个拥有工程学位的成年女性，但在这里我整天坐在家里，不知道怎么问路，或者如果我饿了怎么买食物。我觉得我还不如干脆死掉算了。她说，Tosklivo bilo mne. 托斯卡笼罩了我。
For a long time, I felt like "toska" was a word that belonged to my mother, but not to me. I felt like I didn't deserve to take on a feeling from a place where I'd only spent a year of my life. It felt fraudulent to equate my puny American miserableness with the great Russian toska. I wasn't Russian enough to feel toska, and I didn't deserve to feel depression. Despite having two languages at my disposal, I had no word to cling to.
很长一段时间里，我觉得“托斯卡”是一个属于我母亲但不属于我的词。我觉得我不配承接一种来自我只生活过一年的地方的感受。将我微不足道的美国式痛苦等同于伟大的俄罗斯托斯卡，感觉像是一种欺骗。我不够“俄罗斯”来感受托斯卡，也不配感受抑郁。尽管我掌握两种语言，但我没有一个词可以依靠。
And then something happened. I was with my mother at home in her kitchen. We talked as she waited for holodetz to solidify. And I asked her a question I used to ask all the time as a little girl. I asked her to tell me the story of how we got here. And she told that story the same way she always had, until I asked her about the days when we lived in the apartment on Avenue P, when it was mostly me and her together.
然后发生了一件事。我和母亲在家里厨房。我们聊着天，等着肉冻（holodetz）凝固。我问了她一个我小时候经常问的问题。我让她讲讲我们是怎么来到这里的故事。她依然像往常一样讲那个故事，直到我问起我们在P大道公寓生活的日子，那时主要是我们母女俩在一起。
She sighed. Her hands were covered in a sticky gelatin, so she wiped her brow with the inside of her wrist. Oh, Lera, those were the hardest years of my life. It felt like the shadow had come over me. I definitely felt toska, but it was also, well, probably depression, she told me. It was so casual, so effortless, the way she just said "depression" as if it was nothing, as if it was a word she had been saying all her life.
她叹了口气。她的手上沾满了粘稠的明胶，于是她用手腕内侧擦了擦额头。噢，莱拉，那是我一生中最艰难的几年。感觉阴影笼罩了我。我确实感受到了托斯卡，但那也是，嗯，大概是抑郁，她告诉我。她说的那么随意，那么轻描淡写，就好像“抑郁”这词没什么大不了的，好像这是她一生中一直在说的词一样。
I could see her reflection in the mirror of the microwave, and she didn't even hesitate, just kept on cooking. I sat behind her stunned. Did that just happen? A few weeks later, we were on the phone, and I could tell she was in a strange mood. So I asked how she was doing. Depressed, Lera. I'm feeling depressed, she said. Jeez.
我在微波炉镜面上看到了她的倒影，她甚至没有犹豫，只是继续做饭。我坐在她身后惊呆了。这真的发生了吗？几周后，我们在通电话，我能感觉到她心情很奇怪。所以我问她怎么样。抑郁，莱拉。我感到抑郁，她说。天哪。
This time, I was angry. This is a word she's just using now? Why did she get to use the word she had always denied to me? Did she even have the right to use the word, to redefine her life so late in the game? I resisted the urge to say something cruel.
这一次，我生气了。这是她现在才开始用的词吗？为什么她可以用她一直拒绝让我用的词？她甚至有权使用这个词，在生命这么晚期重新定义她的人生吗？我克制住说些刻薄话的冲动。
Months passed, and I began to realize that I had spent so long feeling that I did not deserve to be depressed that now, I was not allowing my mother to be depressed either. It took me a while to get the courage to finally ask her about it. Why was she suddenly OK with this word? She shrugged. What did you expect? I didn't know what the word really meant until recently. How was I to know that's what I was experiencing?
几个月过去了，我开始意识到，我花了太长时间认为自己不配抑郁，以至于现在，我也不让母亲抑郁。我花了一段时间才有勇气最终问她。为什么她突然接受这个词了？她耸了耸肩。你期待什么？我直到最近才知道这词真正意味着什么。我怎么会知道我经历的就是那个呢？
Coming into this knowing, it wasn't a big moment for her. It was a bunch of smaller ones. She started hearing more Russian speakers use the word in America, on Russian-language TV. She unattached the meaning of that Soviet depresiya from depression. And over time, the word just lost its stigma.
认识到这一点，对她来说并非什么大时刻。它是由一系列小事组成的。她开始听到更多在美的俄罗斯人用这个词，在俄语电视上。她把苏联那种“depresiya”的意思从“抑郁”中剥离出来。随着时间推移，这个词失去了污名。
I didn't think I could feel depression as an immigrant, she said. I thought I could have only been toska. I think if she had said she was depressed, then she'd be admitting defeat as an immigrant. She would be admitting that even here in America, after leaving her home to give her children a better life, things could still feel bad. And all those times my mother told me depression was an American concept-- that I wasn't sick, but just particular, that my mood was temporary or could not possibly exist because I was too privileged in America-- looking at it now, I wonder how much of that was meant for me and how much of it was for her.
她说，作为移民，我不认为我能感受到抑郁。我以为我只能感受托斯卡。我想如果她说她抑郁，那么她就是在承认作为移民的失败。她会承认，即使是在美国，在离开家园给予孩子更好生活之后，事情仍然会感觉很糟糕。而那些我母亲告诉我抑郁是美国概念——我没病，只是特别，我的情绪是暂时的，或者因为在美国太优越而不该存在——现在看着这一切，我想其中有多少是针对我，又有多少是针对她自己。
My mother wasn't wrong in describing how she felt in America as toska. But I think she didn't realize she didn't have to choose between "toska" and "depression." She could have both words. I didn't understand that either. To me, "toska" is the word that comes the closest to the feeling of being a child of immigrants, maybe better than any other word I know. It's the knowledge that no matter how hard you try, you will never see the things your family saw, that you will never understand them fully. And they will never really understand you.
我母亲在描述她在美国的感受为托斯卡时并没有错。但我认为她没意识到她不必在“托斯卡”和“抑郁”之间做选择。她可以拥有两个词。我也没明白。对我来说，“托斯卡”是那个最接近作为移民孩子感受的词，也许比我知道的任何词都要好。这是一种认识，即无论你多努力，你永远看不到你家人见过的东西，你永远不会完全理解他们。而他们也永远不会真正理解你。
It's the yearning for a place your parents claim as home. And it's a word I finally feel is mine. These days, while my mother and I are on the phone and she's cleaning, I'll hear the way she's breathing and ask if she's OK. She'll tell me she's feeling depressed, and I'll tell her that that's OK. There's no shame in that. I feel it too.
这是一种对你父母称之为家的地方的向往。这也是我最终觉得属于我的词。这些天，当我和母亲通电话而她在打扫时，我会听她呼吸的方式并问她好不好。她会告诉我她感到抑郁，我会告诉她那没关系。那不丢人。我也感受到了。
Sometimes when she asks how I'm doing, I'll take an inhale, the kind that gets caught in your throat right before you start to cry. And she'll wait a minute and check I'm still there. And I'll tell her that I feel toska. And she'll say, of course you do. You're my daughter.
有时当她问我怎么样时，我会吸一口气，那种在哭泣前卡在喉咙里的气。她会等一会儿，确认我还在。我会告诉她我感受到了托斯卡。她说，你当然会。你是我的女儿。
Valerie Kipnis, a.k.a. Valeriya, a.k.a. Lera, is a producer on our show. She's working on a memoir about immigrants and untranslatable words.
瓦莱丽·基普尼斯，即瓦莱里亚，即莱拉，是我们节目的制片人。她正在创作一本关于移民和不可翻译词汇的回忆录。
["SEARCHING FOR A NEW WORD" BY CON BRIO]
["寻找新词" - Con Brio]
(SINGING) I'm searching for a new word. I'm searching for a symbol to represent my mind in these shifting times.
（歌唱）我在寻找一个新词。我在寻找一个符号，来代表我在这些动荡时代里的思想。
Our show today was produced by Susan Burton. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Cassie Howley, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Safiyah Riddle, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu.
我们今天的节目由苏珊·伯顿制作。参与制作今天节目的人员包括Bim Adewunmi、Sean Cole、Michael Comite、Cassie Howley、Seth Lind、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Nadia Reiman、Safiyah Riddle、Ryan Rumery、Alissa Shipp、Christopher Swetala、Marisa Robertson-Textor、Matt Tierney、Nancy Updike和Diane Wu。
Our Managing Editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our Senior Editor is David Kestenbaum. Our Executive Editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是戴维·克里斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马纽埃莱·贝里。
Special thanks today to Amy Walters, Nabil Shawkat, Jack Saul, Gisha, Jennifer Kipnis, Matthew Steinberg, and Al Jazeera's podcast, The Take.
特别感谢今天的艾米·沃尔特斯、纳比勒·沙卡特、杰克·索尔、吉莎、詹妮弗·基普尼斯、马修·斯坦伯格，以及半岛电视台的播客《The Take》。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can listen to our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以完全免费收听我们超过800集的档案。本节目由公共广播交易中心PRX传送给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, sometimes I think he doesn't like it in this country at all. When we named our radio show, Torey thought he had a much better name than the one we picked.
一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，有时我觉得他一点也不喜欢这个国家。当我们为广播节目命名时，托里认为他有一个比我们选的更好的名字。
Amerikanskaya zhyzh, meaning America nonsense.
“Amerikanskaya zhyzh”，意思是美国垃圾。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Nonsense.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多这些《美国垃圾》的故事。